i got a text this morning from uh my
buddy nate boyer saying hey
check out what i wrote in the players
tribune if you got a second it is
beautiful
uh and i'm like let's let's uh let's
have nate call in
uh and give some voice to the piece that
again is
posted on the players tribune and um
and it is entitled um uh a note uh
let me make sure i get this correct a
letter to my present self
there it is nate boyer here on the rich
housing show how are you nate
i'm doing okay rich how are you doing i
am doing well sir
so uh i give you the floor on what this
is about and what
you you'd love for people to go to the
players tribune.com
and read about this yeah you know
it's veteran's day obviously and uh
it's an important day for our country
it's a quick important day for a lot of
people and then
it should be an important day for
veterans you know this is sort of uh
it's been a tough year for for everybody
out there in the world
and uh you know gone through a lot of
going through currently going through a
lot of personal growth stuff and
just trying to get to this point and
understanding and that appreciation for
uh myself which sounds really weird to
say and really hard to say i think from
a veteran's standpoint
um people thank us for our service a lot
you know and we're
always willing to help and be there for
one another and be there for other
people as well
um but we struggle a lot with being
there for ourselves
and and loving ourselves and accepting
love
you know and appreciation i think for me
growing up i always felt like i didn't
deserve it
i felt like i i got dealt a decent hand
and it's just not fair it's not fair not
what
that's what led me to do a lot of things
that i did including fighting for my
country which i loved
um and uh
it's just it's torn me apart uh it's
torn me apart because
i've i've tried to do all these big
things and i've spent my whole life
trying to save the world
and not let people help me and save me
you know and uh at the end of the day i
need saving more than anybody
and i just want every veteran out there
listening
and people that aren't veterans you know
that just struggle with that
to understand that you know you are
worth it
you're valuable uh what you did what you
do every day
it is a piece of you good and the bad
but it doesn't define you
and to just appreciate
you know who you who who you are and who
you're trying to be
and just and just be still with that i i
recently lost something pretty damn
important to me the most important thing
to me and
it was in the midst of doing all these
big things that i love
and you know have a have a heart for
but it it wasn't until i completely lost
it
did i realize what i had and uh
and who i had and you know it
in the amount of people an amount of
love that
had been given to me that i just
wouldn't accept that i would just deny
and it hung in the universe for 10 years
maybe longer
20 years i don't know and and now i'm
finally starting to
accept it and feel it and try to just be
open to it and it's
it's really hard it's really heavy um
but it's it's something that i think is
really important
and then it's it's it's just a just a
moment for me right now to reflect on
that and thank myself
and say happy veterans day to myself um
and let people
you know shower me with with uh with
love and that
only then can i i think truly give it
back
um when i'm when i'm willing to receive
it well it's important
it's important and it's important for
you to feel that way nate because
so many people do depend on you to give
it back to them i mean everybody that's
involved with them
you know emerging vets and players and
everybody that does look to you
as a rock you know uh you are a rock for
a lot of people nate
i've seen it in person i know it um
we're showing photographs of it
i mean this is this is a fact so i hope
you do allow people to say this to you
and what you're referring to of what
you've lost
um that it is something that you can um
in some way uh regain uh elsewhere
or through someone else um you deserve
it that's a fact
i appreciate that rich i do we all do
we all really do you know um and so this
is all
in your piece essentially in the players
tribune today or this is the essence of
the piece is what you're saying
yeah i think this is the this is the
essence of it and i i think it's a
you know i think it's i think it's
important like i said not just for
veterans but for
for people on on days like this that
you know i don't know so many of us want
to deflect because we feel like
either either we don't deserve it we
haven't earned it or
it's uncomfortable you know when people
say thank you
and uh uh it's okay to say you're
welcome it's okay
it's okay to take it sure and uh you
know and and it's
i don't know they bang it in your head
man when you're serving that
you know it's it's it's of course you're
not individuals out there
we never are um but also
it's it's it's just hard to
very hard to to accept the
accept gratitude i guess um i don't know
why
i really don't know why and a lot of it
i mean a lot of us it's it's growing up
and that's what we that's why we ran to
the military we wanted to fight for
something bigger than us because we felt
like we weren't
worth fighting for and uh it's not true
it's not true it is not true and
everyone check out again this piece at
theplayerstribune.com
um and uh check out nate at nate nate
boyer37
uh and check out uh again merging vets
and players it's an incredible
organization um
before i let you go nate i'm seeing you
sunday right i'm seeing you sunday
you're seeing me sunday that's right at
nfl network there
tell tell tell my buddy chris brockman
everybody else in the audience what are
we doing sunday
this is fun well you know it's blue
service month
through the nfl and uh you know today is
veterans day and
obviously we want to honor everybody
that served every day but it's a it's a
special time to really reflect on that
and uh you know so just be able to be
able to come in
and uh and share these stories again
share our stories
honor one another lift each other up i
know you know the difference between
memorial day and veterans day we
actually talked about this on memorial
day on your show rich
um but there's still there's still an
element of of honoring that those who
don't that didn't make it back to or
those that are back home right now
and are struggling you know left a piece
of them overseas a big piece of them
um we got to bring them all home you
know and so for me like that's what
veterans
veterans day is all about and when we
come in uh when we come in
on sunday for nfl never because it's an
opportunity um for once again the
you know the league to show uh their
support there's a there's an
incredible partnership not just through
mvp um but through
i think a lot of the players in the
league and organizations and fans
um and the military and uh and salute to
services is a really important month
uh and especially this year you know we
need to go we need to love on each other
a little bit more
and we need to appreciate each other and
this is an opportunity to do that well
i'll give you a virtually
uh uh a social distant hug when i see
you on sunday
and i i appreciate the time and uh you
you know please do accept
my gratitude and everyone's thanks you
deserve to do that and so do
all of the men and women uh who have
served and
those as we remember today who did not
come home
truly nate you're the best yes sir thank
you rich i love you brother
back at you right back at you i'll see
you soon that's nate boyer